[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i saw where matt corral had his pro day
and of course he had a great pro day
who you know i'm waiting for sam howell
to have his pro day and people are going
to be gushing over him but you know matt
corral man he showed some uh scrambling
ability who scrambles doing during her
pro day
like were there ball boys chasing him
was there a was there an actual lion on
the field chasing him but we're making a
big man matt corral showed some mobility
there do these guys watch these guys
during the year
uh i know chris sims does pro football
talk live co-host good to have you on
chris let's uh start with your immediate
reaction when you heard the chiefs
let tyree kill go to the dolphins
well shocked i think shocked and sad all
right i think a little bit of both i
mean shocked because it was just like
wow it all happened so fast wait there's
rumors that he might be traded they
allowed him to seek a trade wait all of
a sudden it was wait it's down to the
dolphins and jets in no time and then
boom it happened so that was the
shocking part sad because
hey this is one of the it's been one of
the greatest combinations in the history
of football and unique at that i mean
again it's it's a young quarterback in
mahomes who took the league by storm
with tyree kill who's you know one of
the fastest people we've ever seen in an
offense and a plan of attack that was
new that we had never seen the football
hey just you know run 70 yards that way
run 50 yards that way run 40 yards that
way stop and then run 40 yards the other
way we never saw anything like that so
that's where i'm sad because yeah i
think it will go down as one of the more
fun you know greatest duos or
combinations we've ever seen in the nfl
okay can you make a case for the chiefs
in this situation
i can make a case for the chiefs you
know the chiefs first saw a very
well-run organization you look at their
football team they're not big into
giving second contracts to guys who are
at 30 or getting above travis kelsey's
about the only guy you can think of
there how many guys can you pay towards
the top of the market on your football
tent you know again last week
everybody's mad at aaron rodgers because
he took all the money but then with
kansas city it's like well hey they got
my homes they're paying top market
dollar chris jones is being paid top
market dollar kelsey's being paid top
market dollar orlando brown who they
traded for last year he's a franchise
left tackle they're gonna have to pay
him top market dollar so this is one i
think they looked at age 28 all right um
you're getting close to 30 maybe dropped
a little speed this past year we can't
pay you 28 million dollars a year we got
to move on and do something better for
the team and i i i don't fault them for
that with the amount of money he was
asking for give me the quarterback under
the most pressure
this upcoming season
out of those two you mean my home's
intuition no you can throw everybody
into the pool here you can throw rogers
in there russell wilson you can throw
derrick carr in there sure yeah it's
it's it's interesting you know i look at
first off with like you know my homes i
know everybody looks at it i think i
think first off tyree kill is a better
receiver than devonte adams i do so but
i also look at that and go i don't know
wait wait what what makes him better
than devonta adams um you know the fact
that he can basically score from any
part of the field you know whether it's
a reverse a toss sweep a slant route you
know oh there's you know 20 seconds left
in the game we're gonna throw you a 20
yard in cut and then can you run by the
rest of the team in buffalo for the
other 70 yards like that's special
there's a very few people that can do
that so that i i am one that's maybe
different that error on that kind of guy
the deimos samuels the jamar chases of
the world over the devonte adams davonte
adam's awesome don't don't get me wrong
but i look at with kansas city too and
go i don't again it hurts them but i
don't go oh well they're no longer you
know a legit super bowl contender i
don't think that green bay without
devonte adams i do have that thought a
little bit because they were so centric
around just the rogers devonte adams
connection
but you know pressure
that's a really good question first off
tua has pressure on him now for sure you
got no excuses the o-line's good you got
the weapons you got the offensive
coordinator they're going all-in on you
there's nothing we can say here that you
don't really have to be successful he's
one guy i look at to be up there in that
category i do think rogers is up there
in that category um yeah i think those
are probably the guys that jump off to
me uh more than more than others right
now okay uh assess tua he's going into
his third year here yeah still feels
like they're not sure what they have
right you know i think this is a double
down move to go wait wait we're going to
make it work or you know or we've given
you everything to try to make it work
and it didn't look that good this year
maybe you're not the guy i think that's
kind of like brings it all to a pinnacle
here to go all right he's either the guy
or he's going to prove himself that he's
not the guy with this type of weaponry
not a huge arm you know that we know
that everybody knows that right but
still you know good athlete has good
feel for the game you know he is good in
the pocket he's got some different
deliveries you know coming out of
alabama everybody was like hey he's like
a point guard right i i would agree with
that you know he makes a lot of great
passes he doesn't make a lot of great
throws you know throws are what i look
at 20 yard out route you know in the
hole down the sideline 30-yard gain
that's not what he is but i think with
mike mcdaniel the offense they're going
to run there right it's gonna be the
shanahan zone scheme oh wait it's waddle
going this way oh they faked it to him
oh no they're throwing to tyree kill in
the slant round the second level like we
see debo samuel he's got two demo
samuels in his offense basically now so
he's got that and then i think tua with
the movement the bootlegs pretty quick
release good short ball thrower that's
where it fits them and i think that's
the formula they're going to try to
replicate down there see i think waddle
is really the key to this
because i hear you you know i got a
rookie contract i got a guy you can you
can have him on every down catching
balls
tyreek hill is more of a we need a big
play where wado is the guy who's going
to have a hundred grabs it feels like
yes i would agree waddle is unique and
you know
really really fast you know maybe just a
little not as fast as tyrique but it's
real fast
but he's also a very good underneath
route runner too and he can do that
julian adam and wes welker type of stuff
as well that's where it is unique and
you know again there's two guys that put
tremendous stress
on a defense because of their ability to
make big plays from anywhere throw a
screen to them these guys can go 70
yards down the sideline you couple that
dan with the offense itself guseki at
tight end oh my gosh and then hey
they're making some nice moves a running
back with chase edmonds and mozart and
company i look at it and go man miami we
know the defense was good and now the my
the offense is rounded into the shape
here that's one of the more talented
rosters in the nfl i know that uh i
always respect your opinions when it
comes to quarterbacks going into the
draft
and uh i'm prefacing that because i saw
where the number one quarterback
according to chris sims of pro football
talk
is matt corral
right ole miss quarterback matt corral
right all right the floor is yours
okay
uh you know again this is uh
a guy that's got
i knew he was talented i turned it on i
guess i was a little bit more blown away
by his talent than i thought you know
first thing i'll just hit you with this
banner statement he has three
things that he does at an elite level to
me that like the nfl is going to look at
and go dan that's that's special
first off his arm is extremely strong i
mean it's like crazy strong to where you
go man did he really throw that ball 25
yards out route and it was like five
five feet off the ground the whole way
there like you had to almost rewind it
to go wait did that really do that the
whole way there so big time arm quickest
release in the draft quickest release
i've seen in any draft since i've gotten
into this side of the business dan that
i would say that and then as an athlete
quickness in his feet is elite and as
good as anybody i've ever seen his
ability to pop around the pocket you
know get his feet situated and make a
throw is phenomenal oh fake a little rpo
boom hit the feet
get the ball out of his hands it's as
quick as anybody i've ever seen it's up
there with the rogers and my homes have
been able to flick it and do all that so
i really like him i do i think he's a
good athlete he throws the ball on the
run play action pass is the thing in the
nfl right now he thrives on that he
hasn't put it all together yet
but it's all going in the right
direction i think you couple that with
the skills i see in the field i go yeah
he's the first quarterback for me okay
is he a top
10 pick
i i
you know again i'm different here but i
sit here and you know what i want to say
dan i mean if two was the number five
pick then yes matt corral is a top ten
top you know pick that way
but you know again the off the field
stuff goes into that you know you hear
rumors he was a little bit of a wild
college kid okay what would he do i
don't care about all that crap i'm just
going about what i see on the field here
uh but
i do think his talent warrants that now
you know is he
polished and ready to go this second no
you'd have to you know use them in
special ways and slowly bring him along
but i don't think anybody is polished
you know willis isn't pickett isn't uh
pick it pickets a little more than the
rest he's the safest bet i would say
like you know he's the closest to a what
you would want to say like the mac jones
last year he's been in a pro-style
offense you get to see a lot of that he
can really play the position well dan
everything is good there's nothing he
does great to me there's there's his his
grade is just that he really knows how
to play the position and has a lot of
experience you make all the throws he's
a good athlete he's got good size i
don't watch can he pick it ever and go
wow oh wow he does that oh my gosh i
love that i don't ever say that with
corral
and
and willis i do say that and i would say
yes i think corral and willis their
ceiling is higher than somebody like
kenny pickett all right i have great
respect for your opinions there thanks
mike thanks buddy i appreciate it even
though you know you guys think jim
harbaugh could beat me up other than
that you guys are cool with me
you think you could beat up harbaugh
yeah
yes i do of course i wouldn't say it if
i didn't think it i mean yes yes
right
how about you know like jake paul was
always trying to get guys to fight on
his card there uh oh yeah yeah you so i
don't know about that
jake paul can box he's gonna no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no you
no you'd be on the card the undercard oh
yeah hey money's right let's get it done
let's get it going i'm ready for it i
mean it seems like jake paul's doing all
this stuff and these guys are getting
paid i'm down for that okay let's do it
but you think then i could get your dad
to fight harbaugh's dad
well that that's one where i got a lot
of respect for mr harbaugh there but he
might be a little too old for big phil
at this point yeah so you would take
horrible okay
yeah yeah all right don't start that
again i'm just having fun all right
are you
no i'm kind of not
[Laughter]
just reminding you guys what side you
took if that ever happened i would take
hardball i would take i know you're i'm
afraid of harbaugh i i didn't i was
supposed to sign you know fill out the
ncaa bracket yeah for you guys in the
show and and i i meant to and all and
all i really did i got a little busy
last week i had to travel
and and then i no no joke i honestly
thought about you know they think
harbaugh can take me screw their bracket
i'm not doing it okay i felt good that's
how i justified it in my brain
we
we didn't lose
i mean adam sandler wasn't too busy will
ferrell wasn't too busy uh yeah cause
they're sitting on piles of 100 million
dollars
elon musk wasn't
another oh yeah another guy he's busy
tweeting all day
i want my new tesla it's taking forever
it's a year and a half stop tweeting
elon musk get to work and get me my damn
car okay
thank you chris
thank you that's chris sims pro football
talk live co-host he loves matt corral